[Music]
what I want to argue is that and I'm
gonna be abstract for a minute but this
will get concrete very quickly is that
even if a broad-based cultural
relativism doesn't work for people
anymore it doesn't give moral difference
a role to play in our lives anymore that
people are attracted to I still think
that the study of the various ways
cultures define the good can help us
find a role for cross-cultural
differences in our moral life okay even
if we don't want to be full-blown
relatives and say we're just going to
tolerate anything that makes sense to
other people I think that studying the
ways people define the good still can
help us develop our own moral
understandings and in in working to
substantiate that point I'm gonna
suggest two different ways that a focus
on different notions of the good is not
the same thing as relativism okay I'm
gonna try to convince you that looking
at the kind of differences I looked at
in the first half between different
versions of the good isn't quite the
same thing as what relativists used to
be up to and that it's for this reason I
think that focusing on differences in
croix in definitions of the good across
cultures can help us think about how
cultural differences can matter for our
own lives so first I want to note a
crucial way in which a focus on cultural
understandings of the goods leads us to
dwell on very different kinds of
differences than the relativist dealt
with that's my first thing we could call
that an empirical point I'm gonna say
that the differences that we focus on
the differences that are out there in
the world that we choose to focus on are
gonna be different if we see ourselves
as doing a comparative study of the good
across cultures as opposed to doing a
relative study just of cultural
difference in general so that's the
first point we're gonna look at
different things but then I also want to
draw on a philosophical position known
as value pluralism to suggest why a
focus on the good can can allow for a
different use of data on moral
difference than relativism did so first
I want to talk about the the kinds of
differences in the world we're going to
attend to if we focus on different
definitions of
then I'm gonna make a philosophical
argument in conclusion about why
focusing on differences in the good is a
different project than trying to become
a tolerant relativist so first onto my
point about the fact that this
cross-cultural study of differences in
the good is a little different than
relatives if you think about it and
probably some of you have done this
yourself when when anthropologists or
philosophers or people in their own
everyday conversations want to make
relativist arguments what do they focus
on in other cultures well they tend to
focus on things they find morally
upsetting they tend to focus on things
they find pretty repugnant when you're
about to have or you know somebody's
gonna make a relative Targ yym n't when
they say to you something like well I
bet you think arranged marriage is bad
or I bet you think ritual genital
modification is bad or I bet you think
infanticide is bad or there's a
wonderful anthological article a few
years ago that actually started with the
sentence I bet you think child labor is
bad I knew I was in for a good article
when she started with but relatives
always want to start you with something
that you find morally repugnant but
something you basically find as it were
disgusting and then their technique is
to tell you enough about the culture it
comes from that maybe you could
appreciate why it makes moral sense in
its own local cultural terms okay so to
play this level of this game you've got
to be focusing all the time on practices
that your audience finds disagreeable
that they just spontaneously dislike
what that means is that the full range
of cultural differences never really
comes into focus and relativists
conversations at best you'll get the
practice that you find upsetting or
disturbing you know we'll take
infanticide for example and then you'll
get the cultural ideas that make sense
of it but the focus really is on the
practice that that you don't like the
focus is very rarely on what those two
societies define is the good that
they're trying to reach it is also
true and this is a slightly subtle point
but I'm only gonna dwell on it for a
minute so don't worry if it doesn't make
a lot of sense but when you when you
make a relativist argument you tend to
focus precisely on practices and not
ideas the trick is to hold up a practice
like well these people murder a lot of
children at birth murder and murders
already judgmental turned they they end
the lives of a lot of children at birth
that's infanticide or they practice
arranged marriage or or etc etc etc
you're focused on their practices not on
the goals and ideas that motivate them
to do what they do okay you don't study
why they're motivated to do these
practices when you're just trying to
make a relative's argument and that's a
huge loss because most people's
practices only really make sense when
they're embedded in versions of the good
life and I'm arguing that we should
focus on those versions of the good life
so just take the practice of cueing in
the UK for example right which I know is
a very important part of British culture
that's a practice I could hold it up
just as a practice and in fact in some
places people find that pretty exotic
right the risk take it so seriously
right but the point is to really
understand why British people are so
committed to the practice of queuing and
why it's so important to do it right
you've got to know that it connects up
with very important values about
fairness about people getting what they
deserve about playing by the rules about
punishing people who don't play by the
rules and reporting people who do so if
you just focused on the practices isn't
this weird British people queue up all
the time that that looks immoral pause
you're missing out on the real story
which is the very important notions of
fairness that that practice serves to
put in to play relativism tends to get
obsessed just with the practices
themselves like if you just talked about
queuing and not fairness at its best it
will tell you about a practice that
repels you and then very quickly related
to other aspects of the culture to
kurzon to try to make it seem less
repellant but it won't
on what people in the culture think is
most important and I what I'm trying to
argue is that we would do better in
making cultural differences in relevant
to our own moral lives if we didn't
focus just on the practices but we
focused on the models of the good that
they were trying to realize if we
focused on the fairness and not the
cueing for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you